how much do you think you're 65 minutes
your experience of having your content
getting sort of
consumed by political commentary is that
like marrying the rest of the world you
think it's everybody yeah
like everyone's doing political
commentary yeah yeah because uh
uh i think this was a strategy of the
democrats
they wanted everything to be political
because they needed non-voters to vote
they needed
they needed regular people who don't
care to vote how do you get
some you know 23 year old dude who's
playing video games all day to vote for
joe biden
you scream in their face and take
everything away from them and scream in
their face again and finally by fine
come on joe biden there you go well
leave me alone right exactly
we talked about that a few weeks ago
about the democrats beating their people
over the head gaslighting torturing them
you know
yeah basically threatening them and the
only thing they could do is just vote to
make it stop but part of that comes from
critical race theory
and activists that have like produced
all these people these young kids who've
taken over corporations they're taught
that
politics is personal it's all personal
and you have to make it personal you
have to even get in people's personal
spaces and make people uncomfortable
and it's consumed everything and then
you take away you can't go to the
football games you can't go to the
basketball games you can't go
and you can't do anything the only show
in town is politics i think we may have
crossed the breaking point yeah like the
hard breaking point in this country
so i've talked you know i frequently
said you know we're sitting on the
precipice or maybe we've gone over it
i think we hit the ground i think we
went over the precipice a while ago when
we hit the ground with this election
you know there there was a hearing the
uh today
that's a the windham in gettysburg and
you had a bunch of republicans and they
were witness listening to
testimony and man you had some legit
people there there was one one guy who
was a former intelligence officer who
worked psychological operations
who was testifying you know trump trump
called in but yet a lot of people
speaking
that that whole thing it's weird
it kind of freaks me out well can we can
we just back up for a second set the
stage there like
how do you have a hearing in a hotel
ballroom because it's not official
it makes me wonder like so was anybody
like under oath or sworn
things or anything it was just yeah it
had the feeling of a hearing but it was
really just a sophisticated
or maybe presentation i think what
they're trying to do i don't know i'm
asking i think they're trying to
there there's like a large angry maga
beast
snarling it's like you know what you
know desert is a good example it's it's
it's uh like trying to calm down the
hulk like you know
don't worry hulk like you know you're in
the here's the here's the real hearing
come sit down and
you've got all these angry maga people
that are you know ready to smash
and so they're like we're gonna do a
hearing and then they show up and
everyone's clapping and cheering and
it's like bro
they're putting you in the kitty room
and and and blowing smoke up your ass
now some people out there pl you know
well-known commentators on the right
they saw they saw that
that hearing and and it really changed
the way that they felt about
you know was there some sort of systemic
fraud at play at least in this state
there
and in terms of they don't believe it
anymore but they believe it even more
they know that they believe that that
it's time for the democrats to refute
the allegations that they're serious
enough yeah they're credible enough yeah
that the people mystery of the
allegations are credible enough
that that it demands a refutation
actually proving them to be false
that's why i'm saying we we we went off
the precipice a while ago and
we smacked the ground of the precipice
of what that's what i didn't understand
like the point of no return where
this country's divide was getting worse
and worse every day oh yeah
and jumping off the cliff was the point
where you can't turn back and then
hitting the ground is the point where
that
it's it's just done and now we're
staring at each other and
and people are counting heads none of
this in my opinion
uh matters we've we we know there's
evidence
the media is saying there's not evidence
it's just an absolute lie did you see
that poll and i don't know who conducted
it so i'm not sure exactly if it's 100
accurate but it seemed to suggest
that they pulled biden voters after the
election and asked them had they were
they aware of hunter biden were they
aware they weren't
uh operation warp speed were they aware
of our energy independence under trump
etc etc and they weren't
and they said if they were they would
have voted for trump in a small a small
enough person a large enough percentage
but it was a small percentage
it was like typically around four to
five percent of the people said wow i
wouldn't have voted for biden if that
was the case and that's a huge swing for
trump it would have been sufficient
the media was doing everything in their
power to help joe biden
social media was doing everything in its
power to help joe biden
joe biden did not campaign and got 11
million more votes than barack obama
no way doesn't make any sense tim so
listen i
you come to me and you say dude but
people really hate donald trump i say oh
you betcha
but to beat barack obama without
campaigning
now perhaps you can say i mean hold on
just barack obama
i went out to vote for barack obama man
i was motivated
i waited in line i was proud to vote for
barack obama
i really was in 2008 i certainly was
come to regret it
obviously yeah me too but it was a
moment in time it felt right and like
there was no similar energy around joe
biden but maybe maybe this does prove
once and for all
hopefully not that hate is more
motivating than
than love or hope i'm not i'm not
entirely convinced
that widespread voter fraud is what cost
trump the election i think
i think we got to see evidence i think
what we have right now is
the smoke alarm is going off and smoke
is billing out the windows it's time for
the firefighters to go in there because
we think there's smoke
so you know for me i've seen enough the
investigations need to happen but
here's the point i'm saying where we
smack the ground yeah it's not going to
matter
especially when you have these hearings
now it's silly that they're happening
and you're like a windham or whatever
that's like
what are they doing you know they're
going to do it in a couple other states
i guess but
some of these people man these are these
are when i was listening to the
certification process for michigan
some of the people who called in for
public like to say do not certify
these were like former government
officials yeah these were like uh
you know like relatively high ranked
individuals in various organizations and
government
who have said rattling off all the
evidence calling out the law and they
said
f you f.u man that one guy his name was
like aaron van
langeveld was one of the most feckless
and pathetic people i've ever had to
listen to
it's like you you had a guy say like
under this section of the law it says
for for any reason necessary you can
call in adjournment
like you can adjourn the meeting and he
goes well i can't just make something up
and they're like if you can't certify
which is defined as determining if
something is true
then you can call for an adjournment
until they sort out these
these errors and he goes well i just
don't think that's in the law anywhere
sorry
and it was like he said it like 10 times
and i'm like dude you like it was so
obvious
that he was doing everything in his
power to guarantee this for joe biden
and and you had people like one guy
called in and rattled off a ton of crazy
evidence affidavits
you know sworn statements statistical
anomalies
the the things people had seen and uh
the unbalanced books for instance
70 whatever percent you know signatures
didn't match how many votes were cast
people who had said that they didn't
request absentee ballots but absentee
belts got sent to him anyway things like
that
indeed and this guy goes well you know i
don't know i guess you know whatever i
have no choice you know sorry
it's like you wouldn't exist unless you
had a choice like why would you even be
in that position
you're there for a reason to certify or
you can say i can't certify this because
the books are unbalanced
one one explanation for that is that he
was trying to advance the ball for biden
another explanation is that he was so
soft and scared
and incapable of making a principal
decision or making a hard decision or
taking action or anything like that i
don't think he was trying to advance it
for biden
no i think he's just scared he's a
terrified weak
little man this is the crisis the crisis
of weak men
yeah so when you hear that the wayne
county board of canvassers
some some guy goes on the zoom call and
says your kids probably go to this
school
and they immediately certify yeah
exactly
so this guy who is you know should not
be in a
leadership position he sees that he
immediately says i have to i have to i
have no choice
and the reason he was saying that was
because he doesn't want republicans
getting mad at him but guess what
time and time again i'll tell you this
it's because republicans will do
nothing conservatives nothing
you mean in terms of like fighting
aggressively or so antifa breaks the
rules and gets away with it yep 100
and the only like the only thing
comparable is probably the proud boys
and they typically are defensive they'll
show up and do a rally and then
antibiotics them and then they'll fight
back
but antifa is aggressive and they get
away with it it's overt terrorism
it's low tier terror it's not like
they're showing up with you know with
like you know aks and mowing down you
know kids or anything like that
but they're saying just picking off
trump supporters one by one on the
streets of portland it has happened
but the here's the thing that you want
you want to stay under the radar you
can't do high-profile
attacks like that like rhino did so what
you do is you just put on a mask
and you club people and then eventually
people get scared but cancel culture was
the first start
that was them saying comply or else we
will destroy you
and i'll tell you one of the biggest
problems i would say
it would seem that there's probably like
i don't know four or five percent of
trump supporters who are cowards
they're smart enough to know they need
to vote for him but they were too
terrified of what the left would do to
him to speak out and evangelize on his
behalf
so i said this about all these
celebrities who i know support trump but
refuse to speak up because they're like
oh lose my job
and i'm like you will wake up one day
with a joe biden presidency
and everything you hold dear being
stripped away and you'll say i wish i
had spoken up sooner because i had a lot
of influence and i could have used it
bro you are preaching to the choir on
this one my friend i have
arrows in my back from being out front
people have been free riding on my
willingness to go out there personally
and stump for trump
and advocate for him and say he's the
best choice that we had as far back as
2016.
obviously democrats are horrible he'll
transition everything they destroyed
your career they did
tried hurting your family they did
they'd hurt me they got me
fired and doxed and slandered and all
kinds of horrible things
and yet you know i persist and and i
look around at people who i know
feel the same way but don't speak up and
i'm like i'm out here i'm out here i'm a
lightning rod
i'll say this from now on if anyone ever
whenever i'm ever gonna bring up
not being scared and speaking up i'm
just gonna say be like jack murphy
because people always say tim you don't
have a family you don't know what it's
like
it's like all right well then ask jack
because you you stuck your neck out you
were speaking out
they came for your family and you pushed
twice as hard after the fact indeed
you weaponized it i had to you know this
energy came at me it was negative energy
it was this terrorism info terror
like uh character assassination etc and
they came after me and i jiu-jitsu
around into something positive there was
you know it was an opportunity i mean
when you
see the world in terms of opportunity
and energy and you see it all coming at
you and you have a chance to turn around
into something good
you know i seized on it and plus
living well is the best revenge there's
no question about that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you